[Music]
right finally
we have thorson hoffman who's the
producer of the cryptopia film
thanks peter
five years ago i made a film about the
history of money banking and bitcoin
buckle up we said it's gonna be a bumpy
ride
and now some of the big brains and big
egos who championed cryptocurrency claim
they are building a crypto utopia
magical things will happen
it's something called blockchain
technology and it just might change your
life and they really could compete with
if not even take down the facebooks and
the googles and the amazons
my name is thorsten hoffman and i'm
going to put some of these claims to the
test
some critics say you kind of hurt the
community what's your response to that
this innovation has enabled a lot of
criminals and scammers
but basically looking at it now you lie
to us
forget all the hype we'll explore the
true potential of this new invention
see who is already using it
making it really easy and simple for
people to own a piece of a solar farm or
a wind farm
and go deep into a secret bunker
that holds billions in bitcoin
and we cannot talk too much about it
because it's pretty secret what is down
there right
if bitcoin succeeds it will be at least
a million dollars per coin
we learn lessons from the past and meet
those building the future but there are
those who want to kill it
join with me in introducing a bill to
outlaw cryptocurrency so that we nip
this in the bud
control it next year people are going to
start seeing that we have hundreds of
patents and
everything changes or change the world
with it
welcome to ground zero in the battle for
the future of the internet
web 3.0 they wanted a science fiction
dream what they actually did was build a
forthcoming disaster a lot of people
were not willing to learn and we're not
willing to admit they were wrong they're
idiots
stop telling me that i have no clues
that's just [ __ ] if you don't
support free speech you don't support
bitcoin you're an enemy of bitcoin
this is bigger than the internet the
iron age the renaissance the industrial
revolution this affects the entire
world
[Music]
for years and years i've been
researching blockchain technology
cryptocurrencies the market booms and
busts and many have asked me to explain
bitcoin to them but i think this is why
it's so difficult
cryptocurrencies everything you don't
understand about money combined with
everything you don't understand about
computers
okay let's start slowly with the basics
of money and its creation
the total value of all the world's money
is about 120 trillion dollars
what you probably didn't know is that
each new dollar is created by
governments and banks as debt which
needs to be paid back by someone in the
future with interest that's why there
isn't enough money in the world to repay
all that debt
and there never will be
oh and almost all of the world's money
is already digital just entries in a
ledger usually managed by a bank
only a small portion exists as physical
currency like cash or coins think of it
this way
your employer deposits a thousand
dollars into your bank account then you
pay 200 in taxes
500 for rent
200 for bills and shopping and so forth
whether you use credit cards debit cards
paypal or bank transfers they're all
just pluses and minuses in different
digital ledgers that's why there's
almost no need for physical money in our
daily lives
during the financial crisis in 2008 a
mysterious figure called satoshi
nakamoto published this nine-page white
paper it said with bitcoin's open source
software we can create our own money
without banks or governments
[Music]
this new nerd money called
cryptocurrency is created and stored in
computers and before long there was a
growing fan club mostly guys like roger
veer
today he's a polarizing figure but back
then he gave away thousands of coins to
kickstart the movement and they all
called him bitcoin jesus
i think that for many years
he brought more people to bitcoin than
anyone else and we will forever be
grateful to him for doing that
when i was a kid i was reading all these
science fiction books they were talking
about how the world is going to be when
we have this like anonymous digital
cache that people can use on the
internet that's not controllable by
anybody and then when bitcoin came along
it was like wow the science fiction
money that i've been reading about as a
kid is finally here so i got so excited
about it i heard about it about 10 in
the morning and i was planning to go to
work that that day but i didn't i stayed
home the entire day reading about it
didn't leave i stayed up all night that
night reading about it stayed up all
night the next night he went deep down
that rabbit hole to the point of
physical exhaustion the hospital said i
called up a friend of mine i said please
help me i'm so sick can you bring me to
the hospital yeah roger got bit bad by
the bitcoin bug
because it's truly one of the most
exciting inventions ever in the entire
history of humankind
but how does it work
when my friends ask me to explain well i
often start with this analogy
imagine a bank vault where you have a
safety deposit box
your key opens one of the boxes where
you can securely store physical
valuables like gold coins
in bitcoin there are digital keys
think of them as very long passwords
your private key gives you access to a
wallet which unlocks billions of unique
bitcoin addresses
each one is a virtual safety deposit box
that only you can open with your key
and there are more addresses in this
virtual vault than atoms in the
universe the doors to these boxes are
transparent you can see inside them
here's one with digital money 0.21
bitcoins
sending them from one box to another is
what's called a bitcoin transaction
we'll explain that later but for now
just remember that these digital coins
can only exist inside these transparent
address boxes
can't be copied and can't ever leave the
vault
and this vault is owned by no single
entity you don't need permission from a
government a bank or a corporation to
use it
[Applause]
[Music]
for most early adopters of bitcoin it
was all about global peer-to-peer
electronic cash
room 77 in berlin was one of the very
first businesses to accept bitcoins as
payment for physical things
beers and burgers
back in 2011 there were no mobile
wallets right so you had to go there
bring your laptop type you know this
long address you know risk losing the
money if you didn't type it correctly
so the the first guy who built the
motorbike was some guy in berlin who
built it in order to buy his beer with
his phone instead of his computer
the octopian
it
credit cards are an old technology and
actually pretty complex
and your payment details are shared with
many middlemen
each of these parties are also taking a
cut of the action
which is built into the price of nearly
everything you buy
if you purchase something
internationally double the number of
middlemen and triple the fees
credit cards handle almost 20 trillion
dollars of transactions per year
early bitcoin adopters like room 77
avoided paying credit card fees but
york's real beef was with the bankers
who collect them from problems
big to fail too big to jail
in hsbc's arctic spacecraft
collapsing economies murder i didn't
sign up for this
let me get a drink
well actually i need to buy my german
crew some hot glue vine and explain why
they won't get paid until after
christmas
you see transferring money from
australia where i live to germany can
take several days and it will cost 30
plus exchange fees
just for updating numbers and digital
ledgers
[Music]
after all it's just moving data i can
send a picture or video to anyone on the
planet almost instantly for free
we live in the age of the internet but
the banks won't send the data after 5 pm
or on a weekend that doesn't make any
sense
so what if those slow and expensive
middlemen with their multiple ledges
could be replaced by a giant database
synchronized over the internet that's
the big idea behind bitcoin and it's run
by a decentralized global network of
powerful mining computers and regular
laptops
here's how it works
when i pay my cameraman what's really
happening is that i use my key to open
my wallet and then instruct the network
to send bitcoins to his address
most bitcoin apps use qr codes to
identify an address you scan it then
swipe to use your key and approve the
transaction
this information is shared throughout
the global network within seconds
[Music]
every 10 minutes or so
one minor using a tremendous amount of
energy beats all the others in a contest
to solve a very difficult math problem
that miner is authorized to arrange the
most recent transactions into a
structured block and is rewarded in
bitcoins for this work
all of the data contained inside each
block is represented by a checksum
the miner now adds the new block to the
previous one that's why it's called the
blockchain
now the ledger will be updated globally
the checksums of the previous block
match the beginning of the new one which
are baked together forever
it's impossible to tinker with the data
inside the block without changing the
checksums and breaking the chain
this immutability is the first rule of
bitcoin it means no one can ever change
what was once recorded in the blockchain
or spend the same coin twice that's also
called censorship resistance and it's
critical to bitcoin being used as real
money
[Music]
award-winning journalist laura shin
tells me a story about women bloggers in
afghanistan being paid in bitcoin
one of the women had an abusive husband
and saved up her bitcoins and eventually
was able to divorce him because she was
able to control her money when she
earned the bitcoins
in my first film the early adopter said
that this kind of financial freedom for
everyone was just around the corner
world's most populous network
is adopting bitcoin that's the internet
the world's largest economy is adopting
bitcoin that's the internet we have
transcended borders it's totally filed
as electronic cash david gerrard says it
has unbanked the bank more than it has
banked the unbanked he's an outspoken
critic of this technology
it's not very good as a payment system
there's a small payment use case if you
want to
trading things that the government
doesn't want you to trade in
that's david's polite way of saying
illegal stuff
in 2011 most of my partner colleagues
were saying three things yeah so whether
the drugs pornography arm sales
the silk road was a black market on the
dark web where buyers and sellers used
bitcoins to fly under the radar of the
authorities
it had 1 million users until the fbi
showed up and shut it down
they caught this guy for running it and
confiscated the coins held in escrow by
snatching his computer and then they
locked him away for life seems like a
pretty straightforward case of law
enforcement doing their job but in
crypto not everybody sees it that way
people have an absolute right to put
whatever they want in their own bodies
because their bodies belong to them
that makes ross ulbricht and the users
of the silk road heroes not criminal law
breakers in a bad sense uh they were
criminal law breakers in a good sense
the same way that harriet tubman or rosa
parks or you know thomas jefferson or or
george washington were
no doubt cryptocurrencies can be a tool
for criminal activity
but so are dollar bills or the banking
system
and let's not forget
the blockchain is a public ledger
it's actually been quite useful for
uncovering crimes a former federal
prosecutor named katherine hahn she was
the one who discovered that there were a
couple federal agents that
um were pilfering the bitcoins that the
government had obtained from the silk
road case for their own gain
and what was interesting was she got a
tip that there might be one uh one agent
that was doing this but from looking at
the movements on the blockchain itself
she realized that there were two people
the prosecutor could see those bitcoins
being moved and when the dirty cops
tried to sell them for dollars
they got busted
but what makes bitcoins worth stealing
why do they have value at all
let's go back to where bitcoins are
stored in transparent digital deposit
boxes
protected by strong cryptography they
can never be copied or leave the vault
because any transaction of any bitcoin
down to a 100 millionth fraction is
recorded in the blockchain for eternity
this synchronized global ledger is
shared among thousands of computers
worldwide that's why it can't be
compromised or altered think about that
we can make an infinite number of
perfect digital copies of a movie a song
any file but for the first time in
history this distributed record keeping
allows us to have a truly unique and
fungible digital object that is also
scarce
if you could count all of these virtual
coins you'd find about 18 million of
them today
the mining reward is the only way new
coins are created
in the first years of bitcoin miners
competed for 50 bitcoins every 10
minutes
then their reward for processing
transactions dropped to 25 bitcoins
then 12.5
and then half again and again every four
years
it's good old-fashioned supply and
demand
if investors or users of bitcoin create
a higher demand than this decreasing
supply the price will go up
when the cap of 21 million is reached
the protocol stops the network from
creating any more
it's the opposite of our traditional
money supply which keeps growing and
growing
an unlimited amount of dollars versus a
very limited supply of bitcoins you do
the math
if you use euros or dollars you might
not care about a little inflation per
year but if your currency isn't stable
you might be a trillionaire in paper and
be dead broke
i grew up in patagonia in the southern
part of argentina my parents are ship
ranchers there and i remember growing up
in my childhood i saw my parents lose
everything three times
first because of a huge devaluation then
because of hyperinflation and the last
time because the government confiscated
all
of bank deposits i think that today
there are
billions of people at least four billion
people who would be a lot better off by
having access to a form of money that is
non-political and more democratic
we think of finance we think of banking
we think of money
in terms of the experience and
perspective of a western european or
developed nation person
and that
is really just a billion and a half
people who have a very privileged
financial life what about the other six
billion every single country that is
free
has
um
essentially a legal status for
cryptocurrencies that is very open and
permissive and every single country that
is unfree has a restrictive or banned
cryptocurrency status
this is the berlin wall still a powerful
symbol of a government trying to control
its citizens
but this is what happens when people
want to be free
the very first open crypto war is
playing out in venezuela where the local
currency loses value every hour due to
hyperinflation a lot of people in
venezuela are trying to mine
cryptocurrencies and the government
views this as a threat obviously because
they're trying to keep the boulevard
propped up the government actually
provides electricity to a lot of people
and if they perceive that your
electricity has usage has gone up they
will come and check if you have mining
equipment in your house and they will
confiscate it if they if they find it
and that brings us to the big question
can governments or banks ban bitcoin so
the title is jamie dimon here's why
you're wrong about bitcoin
diamond runs jp morgan chase one of the
largest banks in the world that moves
six trillion dollars every single day oh
you said of bitcoin eventually it will
be closed
and then i said to anyone who knows
anything about the technology this is an
incredibly absurd statement
um i even said it was a little bit
hilarious because actually i did find it
kind of funny the idea that he thought
you could close bitcoin you'd have to
shut down the internet
which also doesn't make sense i could
understand if you wanted bitcoin shut
down or hoped it was a fraud i mean if i
were you and if i really understood the
disruption crypto assets could bring to
financial services i'd be very scared
and i think whatever jamie dimon says or
things about bitcoin is as relevant as
whatever the postmaster general thought
or said about email
who cares
then i wrote sincerely laura shin
but some politicians still think they
can stop open source software
i look for colleagues to join with me in
introducing a bill to outlaw
cryptocurrency purchases by americans
so that we nip this in the bud in part
because
not a awful lot of our international
power
comes from the fact that the dollar is
the standard unit of international
finance and transactions clearing
through the new york fed is critical for
major oil and other transactions
and it is the announced purpose of the
supporters of cryptocurrency to take
that power away from us
cryptocurrency represents a litmus test
for governments
it
reveals how much your government
believes in uh
in the fundamental freedoms and and
human rights because
if they don't trust their own citizens
to have control over their own money
that says a lot about the governments
there's very little about cryptocurrency
you see the reason why some governments
and most banks are threatened by this
technology is simple your private key
and your wallet can replace your bank
account
the network is run by software and its
currency is made and maintained by
computing power and electricity it can't
be manipulated by central bankers wall
street lobbyists or politicians but with
new freedom comes new responsibility
a simple rule
if you control the keys it's your
bitcoin if you don't control the keys
it's not your bitcoin your keys your
bitcoin not your keys not your bitcoin
your keys your bitcoin not your keys not
your bitcoin
got that if you lose your key you will
never be able to access your coins again
and if someone hacks your computer where
you store those passwords your coins
will be stolen in a second
and remember how wenses family had their
money stolen by their own government
well maybe that's why he built the fort
knox of bitcoin security zeppel most of
our 7 million customers are in emerging
markets in countries
where there's problems with the currency
we have explosions in activities like
venezuela right now or turkey and we
developed this system of vaults where we
have five private keys for each one of
our bitcoin addresses we keep those
private keys
in an offline server that has never been
online will never be online it's inside
the vault the vault is inside a bunker
usually deep underground our main one is
in switzerland in a decommissioned
military bunker
i just had to see it for myself even
though it took months for us to get
cleared for a tour
we were met by christopher oswalt a
former military commander who runs the
place and their representative from
zappo christoph said the guards would
rather shoot us than show us around
i hope he was kidding they need to bring
in the material
to the other side of the personal lock
first up one more check of our ids a pat
down for weapons or any other monkey
business and gear inspection
even the boss was searched
it took nearly an hour to get my team
through security but it was worth it
no other film crew has been allowed
access
we are the largest custodian of bitcoin
in the world because a lot of the
largest holders in the world use us for
security
rumor has it that 10 of all bitcoins are
stored here and in their four other
secret locations
unfortunately i can't confirm any of
those numbers
from the mountain we are getting a lot
of
benefits right earthquake proof
flooding proof
but on the other side you're facing a
lot of additional cost
like maintaining seven independent
backup power supplies
the labyrinth of tunnels deep into the
mountain is interrupted by nuclear grade
doors
it's a level of security applied to all
of the data christoph protects here not
just for zappo
and we cannot talk too much about it
because it's pretty secret what is down
there right are we allowed to film there
no
there were doors that remained shut and
security measures we weren't allowed to
see
and some of those checks may be
biometric including the eye and a finger
print scan and the fingerprint scanner
also make sure that you are alive that
you didn't cut someone's finger and
you're just using it to open a gate so
you must have a pulse
don't don't touch the wrecks
these aren't zeppo's actual servers but
if you've ever wondered what
cryptocurrency thieves dream about it's
sitting somewhere down here unplugged
from the internet but there is
absolutely no way zero way to attack the
the data which is on the cold storage
side but here's my question why do i
need the cold offline servers to be
inside the mountain how can it be in my
basement while these surveys in your
basement
still can be stolen right
so so this is like money
it is data yes it's it's speed and buy
but it is money at the end and a lot of
money and this is why this data center
here is more a bank than a data center
okay let's do a quick recap we now have
billions of dollars worth of data
secured in digital banks deep inside
secret military bunkers
if you don't think bitcoin is already
changing the world's concept of money
you haven't been paying attention
remember mervyn he used to be a senior
executive at deutsche bank his
colleagues once said bitcoin was for law
breakers and troublemakers he now runs
100 million crypto fund out of malta
our research shows that
the crypto markets are going to probably
be worth about 8.7 trillion in 2027
which is a
50x from today exactly
[Music]
most financial analysts say you better
stick to your shares and bonds and
dollars bitcoin is dangerous nonsense
far too risky as investment
to others bitcoin is an escape hedge
that will take them away from risk and
insurance against a financial doomsday
a way out of the debt crisis negative
interest rates trade wars and economic
downturn
they say it's an anti-fragile asset
uncorrelated to financial markets so
who's right here well every time i turn
on the television it gets even more
confusing bitcoin's worth about a little
bit under 200 billion dollars today all
the gold in the world is worth 8
trillion and it could become the next
gold in terms of cryptocurrencies
generally
i can say almost with certainty that
that they will come to a bad ending but
if bitcoin is out there and gold is out
there it can be a participant in
bringing down the dollar i said it's the
mother of all bubbles and is also the
biggest bubble in human history i think
this is a currency a currency that's
really going to work eventually well i
think it is working
and
there will be other currencies like it
that may maybe even better bitcoin is uh
successful only because of its potential
for circumvention
uh
lack of oversight so it seems to me it
ought to be outlawed it doesn't serve
any socially useful function
this film is an investment advice but it
strikes me that most of these tv shows
just want to stir controversy
they don't understand what's going on
but they know that filling air time with
a controversial topic will get them
higher ratings
so how about the general public
in america the younger generation
already starts to trust this new asset
class and whence it says bitcoin may
reach a million dollars per coin
i would say
the biggest financial mistake you can
make right now is to own an amount of
bitcoin that you cannot afford to lose
because it's super risky and you may
lose it
the second biggest financial mistake you
can make is not to own any because
you put one percent of your net worth in
bitcoin most people can afford to lose
one percent of their net worth and if i
am right it's gonna be more than a
hundred percent of your net worth so
with a non-material exposure you change
your life now what you would spend with
your on a romantic weekend with your
wife
say sorry we're not gonna do that this
weekend i'm gonna just buy bitcoin
consider it spent it disappear check in
seven years
i either gave you bad advice and cost
you a weekend or i want a grandkid
called juancito
[Laughter]
but what you fail to mention is that the
currency the microtransactions all of
that is irrelevant right
meaning
all of the cryptocurrencies are way too
volatile for anyone to take them
seriously
hold on let's go back to where we
started bitcoin was created as
peer-to-peer electronic cash that was
the killer app a payment directly from
you to me from me to the coffee shop
i have bought a bag of coffee for two
bitcoin in 2012
which today
cost me twelve thousand dollars in
today's money
that is a deflationary effect
as long as bitcoin keeps doing sudden
increases in prices that's gonna stop
retail use in its tracks
with bitcoin you can send one dollar or
one million dollars worth of value
anywhere in the world you can do it for
free
but basically looking at it now you lie
to us
yeah that's what they all used to tell
me cheap easy fast global unstoppable
i'm not done with you pal but i need to
explain what happened here
every block contains about one megabyte
of data much smaller than a photo you
post on instagram
that means only a limited number of
transactions can fit into each block if
you want your payment to jump the line
you can choose to pay a premium fee or
sit and wait
at one point the blocks became so full
that the transaction time went to
several hundred hours
that's days
and it was more expensive than
international wire services
it got so bad that a bitcoin conference
wouldn't take payment in bitcoins and
he's the guy who promised me moving
money fast and for free
what went wrong
and that's a direct intentional result
of bitcoin core's policies of
intentionally making it slow expensive
and unreliable and roger blames this guy
for bitcoin not becoming a mainstream
global currency
there are no shortage of conspiracy
theories marker
block stream was founded in 2014
the
original co-founders are a lot of core
developers those are the software coders
who continued building bitcoin after
satoshi vanished
roger thinks those guys sabotaged the
scaling of the network so blockstream
could promote its own software solutions
samson says come on the blockchain is
already 200 gigabytes large and growing
every transaction made has to go out to
the whole network and every block that
contains that transaction that is mined
has to also go to the whole network and
it has to be stored for eternity
the argument
more independent miners will continue
running bitcoin and ensure
decentralization
if the blockchain is kept small
in his view this decentralization is
what makes bitcoin valuable a store of
value
so holding bitcoin is also a use case
and that store value hypothesis i cannot
get my head around it's the most
like nutty thing i've ever heard you
know one philosophy could be described
as bitcoin as digital gold and the other
philosophy could be described as bitcoin
as digital cash
the other team said you guys have it the
wrong way around
first bitcoin needs to be usable as a
currency a medium of exchange then maybe
it will become stable and a store of
value
the solution is easy and just increase
the size of the blocks from one to two
four eight megabytes so that more
transactions fit into them
this will lower the fees and people will
start using bitcoin as cash again the
original title of the bitcoin white
paper is bitcoin an electronic
peer-to-peer uh electronic cash system
but you know satoshi's white paper isn't
the bible it's not a religion this stuff
changes um we evolve we might find out
new things why this um
fixation on that white paper um
you know created ten years ago there
isn't any fixation it's not the version
of bitcoin that i got involved with and
it's not the version of bitcoin that i
want to support
so roger joined forces with a
controversial online gambling
billionaire bitmain a chinese crypto
mining company and this guy i'll do
whatever the [ __ ] i want with my money
okay anyway they forced the software
fork which is a split into two separate
blockchains
every holder of bitcoin now also owned
the same amount of bitcoin cash
roger had nothing to do with the
creation bitcoin cash roger didn't know
about it until a few weeks before it
actually happened but still bitcoin
jesus had become bitcoin judas
every revolution is followed by the
counter-revolution which is usually a
purge of the original revolutionaries
people
uh are very passionate about bitcoin um
and
that's why they they show a lot of
emotion when you're part of a tribe you
get very religious about your tribe
making the other tribe almost your enemy
it's very hard to
to debate roger because a lot of what
he's saying is just his opinions and his
emotions you cannot debate someone's
emotions
and then they basically diverted the
entire bitcoin project
into something that wasn't usable as
peer-to-peer cash when he gave his talk
i kind of knew that that whole debate
panel i kind of expected it was going to
go off the rails but i didn't expect
killing babies so that means more babies
are dying in countries around the world
because they have less economic freedom
more people are starving to death
because they have less economic freedom
people are literally dying because of
this i'm not exaggerating this is a life
and death matter
and remember that list of promises the
early bitcoin has championed
cheap easy
fast unstoppable
i forgot one
if you don't support free speech you
don't support bitcoin you're an enemy of
bitcoin censorship shall not be abided
in fact i myself have tried posting just
a direct quote from satoshi nakamoto the
creator of bitcoin uh i think roger
complains a lot about censorship on on
reddit but red is just one of many like
platforms word for word quote from
satoshi without any additional
commentary for myself at all and i've
had that post deleted even though i may
not agree with a lot of things that
roger very is doing now i do sympathize
with him and his frustration with being
censored they're literally censoring the
words of the creator of bitcoin
ultimately this is a forum that these
guys set up to talk about bitcoin and
they can do whatever they want with it
right
when i first started covering the space
everyone was united in their struggle
against the establishment
now the industry has grown so much that
their competing parties propaganda
machines conspiracy theories
looks a lot like politics
the biggest fight within the bitcoin
ecosystem is over at the moment is who
has the right to the name bitcoin but at
the end of the day i think the version
of bitcoin described in the bitcoin
white paper
has the strongest claim to the name
bitcoin than anything else and that's
bitcoin cash
roger owns bitcoin.com and he has every
intention of bringing bitcoin cash to
the masses even if it means that some
people coming to his website think that
they're buying bitcoin but they're
getting bitcoin cash
i think it's fraudulent to say that and
causing people to to buy bitcoin cash
when they actually want
so bitcoin core fans say roger is
hijacking the brand name and bitcoin
cash supporters claim that blockstream
is hijacking bitcoin's development i
mean yeah it is a conflict of interest
because
they're
developing this open source protocol in
a way where
their company can can benefit from it
everything we're doing is open source so
it's not like there's some secrecy or
anything you can see all the code that's
committed and it does go through this
vetting process i mean they have had
influence and i wouldn't say
it's not true but i don't think
they have enough influence to actually
corrupt
bitcoin uh we no longer have anyone
maintaining the project just because we
don't want that
potential conflict of interest
but in a way now they've won the battle
anyway
so who won bitcoin's first war well both
parties got their way
after the split the market valued
bitcoins much higher
and bitcoin cash transaction fees were
much lower
the benefit of the scaling debate or
civil war was bitcoin was battle tested
like a lot of companies and a lot of
powerful people tried very hard to try
to change bitcoin
and they failed this thing that satoshi
nakamoto launched is much more resilient
than anyone even hoped
i know i know you want to find out what
any of this has to do with this new
cryptopia a revolutionary internet we'll
get there i promise but first we need to
go from bitcoin's original blockchain to
hundreds of blockchains
back in 2011 when charlie lee was a
google engineer he wanted a faster and
lighter version of satoshi's
cryptocurrency
and was one of the first to experiment
with the open source software
the actual coding in terms of like the
code differences between bitcoin and
litecoin was actually pretty trivial
and what does that mean in time like
i would say like
four
four or five hours
litecoin was positioned as silver to
bitcoin's gold and its network value
grew to billions of dollars
some critics say well you sold at the
highest point and you kind of hurt the
community what's your response to that
when i sowed no one knew it was the
highest point i didn't know it was going
to be highest point so everyone thought
it was going to keep going up in
hindsight um it was good timing um
selling it at the high but i'm still
focused full time on litecoin adoption
and working on litecoin and micro
development so it's not like i sold and
just quit
um
nobody gets to kind of
dictate how bitcoin
improves or
grows whereas with litecoin um i have a
a strong influence on the growth of
litecoin which is good and bad
it's kind of like um
the difference between a benevolent
dictator
versus a
democracy the benevolent dictator is
more efficient but you have to assume
that the benevolent dictator stays
benevolent let's put a pin in that
litecoin was one of the first
alternative cryptocurrencies or altcoins
some of the early adopters like charlie
made fortunes
soon there were hundreds of coins made
by cryptographers copycats and cornmen
there's a coin for bloggers a currency
for online gamers one with anonymity and
even one for banks but can this
invention unleash something even more
powerful than digital currencies
back in 2014 i met the kid who knew how
to do it hi i'm vittel berderin
co-founder of bitcoin magazine founder
of ethereum and just general bitcoin and
cryptocurrency advocate
just 19 years old vitalik was on a
mission to make money programmable
vitalik is a very very smart guy the
thing about vitalik is he was pushed
away from bitcoin because he had gone to
uh bitcoin core developers and try to
build ethereum on top of bitcoin and and
they basically said nope not interested
so he built a separate blockchain called
ethereum with its own currency called
ether comparison might be bitcoin is
like a spreadsheet and ethereum is like
a spreadsheet with macros
using our analogy ethereum allows you to
store cryptocurrency and computer code
in the same secure box
here's how a smart contract might work
let's say i bet charlie that a litecoin
will be worth 200
on january 1st of next year
we each put an ether into a box along
with a smart contract a simple program
that automatically checks the price of
litecoins on that future date
if i'm right the money goes to me if i'm
wrong it's sent to charlie
a smart contract is neither smart nor
contract it's a dumb program
and it once you understand that all it
is is on program that clarifies a lot of
stuff and the word contract there is in
the meaning of finance
most financial arrangements are pretty
simple and clear-cut a bed with charlie
your home loan an insurance policy just
two parties and some form of exchange of
value based on a set of rules called a
contract the same is true for global
financial markets
think bonds futures derivatives credit
default swaps they're all just contracts
and the world economy runs on them using
middlemen who all charge high fees
proponents say that if we used smart
contracts we could tell the bankers
lawyers escrow agents and wall street
finance guys to take a hike a solo
machine is a smart contract machine
right you stick in a dollar you get a
soda it's very very simple the soda
machine does take statistics and it has
to make sure that you can't scam it by
stealing the soda but ethereum and the
people that are trying to decentralize
this will tell you that that transaction
that smart contract between you and the
soda machine is so critical that it
needs to be globally processed and saved
at a hundred thousand decentralized
computers because it is so sensitive and
in reality 99 of all of these contracts
they don't need this kind of censorship
resistance you know in two years time
and people will see this film on four
years time i think would be an
interesting historic moment also what
we're doing is we're saying we have this
ethereum network inside the ethereum
network there's this asset called ether
and we're actually going to be selling
ether we're going to be selling ether at
a rate of 1000 to 2000 ether for one
bitcoin and that's how we're going to
raise all the money it worked
vitalik figured out a way to fund the
ethereum project and it made his
investors very rich
this new model for fundraising soon had
a name an initial coin offering or ico
ipos and ico sound similar but they have
they're nothing similar the only thing
similar about them is they both help you
raise money
ipos you don't do until you have a
company until you have revenue until you
have users and so you can actually prove
to the public investors that this is a
valuable company that's worth investing
and it's worth buying their stock
icos
it's pre-product you have maybe a couple
people on the team it's just a white
paper
and so people are just buying into
trust into faith that this is something
that will exist and this is the guy who
opened the floodgates
he created a standard called erc20
enabling you or me or anyone to create
an ico
so on the one hand you have these smart
contracts these little programs they can
talk to each other but you have to
define how do they talk to each other
and because everybody now agrees to that
same standard
smart contracts can interact within the
entire ethereum network and the erc20
standard allowed the creation of tokens
the goal here is like ultimately i like
to see eight-year-olds building their
own financial systems
yeah but what if some of these
eight-year-olds are also scammers
so let's say i'm trying to do a ico and
i create a smart contract where i create
a million coins
and one of the transactions is that if
you
send me a hundred dollars i will send
you that many worth of coins
it was a mad gold rush
people realized wow if
if i can just pull a pull together
project in a white paper i can raise
money like a lot of money
some people hawking new coins didn't
actually exist
this handsome chap is the graphic
designer of a bulgarian ico actually
they just posted a photo of ryan gosling
another project raised millions in ether
and then vanished
leaving investors with this website
look loser
that's nice
most of the scam coins were built on
vitalik smart contract platform ethereum
using fabian's token standard
this innovation has enabled a lot of
criminals and scammers
so i would say the amount of
scams in the in in that system are
rather low it sometimes looks bigger
than it is i would i would assume that
the actual scams
purposeful property scams in that system
maybe were like two or three percent i
would say actually most icos were
not scams i would say about two to five
percent of the thousands of icos that
are happening are actually legit
and the rest is
pretty scammy or just not gonna work
can you define
for me what a [ __ ] coin is
um i think it's just a derogatory term
people use
on um coins that they don't like
for bitcoin maximalists people who only
care about bitcoin everything else is a
[ __ ] coin
in my point of view i think a coin that
is kind of a scam is a [ __ ] coin so
people create coins just to get rich
from it uh print a lot of tokens out of
thin air try to pump the price up and
make a lot of money from it and that's
not really providing a lot of value
to the
to the world no value for the world but
they did add value for their creators if
you can print billions of tokens out of
thin air like a central bank well that's
why this guy was one of the wealthiest
men on earth for a brief moment
here's how that happened
there will only ever be 21 million
bitcoins
and its inventor had to earn them by
mining with his computers just like
everyone else there are more litecoins
and even more ether in circulation the
tele capsule portion to fund the
development team
and then there's ripple
they created a hundred billion xrp but
kept eighty percent for themselves and
their clients
and the other 20 they gave as a bonus to
the founders that's how you get to be
one of the richest men on earth
okay maybe i was a bit too harsh on icos
democratizing startup finance can be a
good thing there were many legit
companies raising capital too over the
years i've met many founders who have
real offices with real people trying to
solve real problems
but to bitcoin maximalists bitcoin is
the be all and all of cryptocurrency
other blockchains icos smart contracts
that's all a waste of time
there is no such thing as
blockchain to
revolutionize the healthcare industry
and the automotive production
is
of course there is what you're saying is
a maximalist point of view you are
speaking about uh from a perspective of
of a cult or a sect
my problem is that you are hijacking a
movement of a technology that is far
greater and has far more potential than
just these individuals there's all of
these different things that you could
use blockchain for right and so people
have they're almost like different
ecosystems
and then what you see is almost like an
evolutionary process right where the
blockchains fork and they have the same
ancestries but they adapt to different
environments and we see this like
ever-increasing level of diversity in
number of blockchains so i think the
idea that there's like one blockchain
gonna be one blockchain and it's gonna
be fit for everything it it's
almost like disregarding the nature of
evolution
meanwhile the big corporations have been
studying cryptocurrency and they think
that bitcoin's underlying database is
where the magic is the model in the
boardrooms
blockchain not bitcoin
[Music]
back in germany my friend oliver keeps
tabs on the men in suits he used to be
one of them
[Music]
bmw is looking at using the blockchain
for the future fleet of electric cars to
interact with public transport
lufthansa wants to see if the blockchain
can better track parts and maintenance
and deutsche telecom is using smart
contracts to negotiate tariffs for
roaming costs with other telecoms
if we can store trade certificates and
shipping documents on the blockchain you
can check to see where those organic
avocados really came from who grew them
who packed them and who shipped them
besides the internet of things needs a
ledger of all those things
well that's the idea behind private
centralized blockchains maintained and
controlled by corporations a famous
example the walmart supply chain trial
which they're working with ibm
that's completely centralized they use a
blockchain derived product hyperledger
but all the nodes reside on the ibm
cloud and they're all administered by
walmart and their suppliers use it
because walmart told them to
it's a centralized database system but
they marked it blockchain so that means
one
they wouldn't have got a new york times
headline
if they just said database
you might wonder what's the point of a
blockchain if it's controlled by a
company
well i compare it to the open internet
versus company owned intranets they both
exist
meanwhile facebook announced the
cryptocurrency for their 2 billion users
such a system might be more efficient
than a public blockchain but there's a
downside
some governments banned it within weeks
[Music]
pieces of paper that's being shifted
around that doesn't make any sense that
infrastructure needs to be replaced why
occupy wall street when we can build a
new one on the blockchain instead
in the future of decentralized finance
stock certificate corporate bonds
insurance policies property deeds
mortgages all can be turned into crypto
tokens and made tradable 24 7.
[Music]
uh
what's much more exciting than tokenized
securities of traditional businesses
where it's just equity that you pass
around is totally novel digital
securities that
you couldn't do before right novel use
cases where you could kick back cash
flow on a continual basis
i think some examples of this that we're
seeing now are maker dow
binance which is that has binance coin
that's actually much bigger of an
opportunity because it represents
something totally new
my name is dr gemma green and i'm a
co-founder and the chairman of power
ledger and we use the blockchain to
enable electricity trading energy asset
financing and carbon markets this
award-winning australian company wants
to take us to a carbon-free economy
faster gemma has identified a problem
apartment buildings often the buildings
are tenanted and it means that if there
is solar panels the owner of the
apartment isn't really incentivized to
put in solar panels or batteries because
the tenant benefits but using our
platform the tenant will pay the
electricity bill to the body corporate
using power ledger the tenant pays the
owner not the power company for the
electricity if the tenant isn't at home
the unused energy will be sold to a
neighbor lowering their power bill and
making a profit for the owner so it
actually creates the mechanism to
justify investing in the capital in the
first place this system could speed up
investment in sustainable energy
projects by making it easy to own a
piece of a solar or wind farm
do i need a blockchain for this can't i
invest in a solar farm without this new
fancy tech the blockchain acts as a kind
of asset register and income register
and in tokenizing the asset it becomes
tradable on an exchange you might own
two or three solar panels of a thousand
in a you know in a solar farm and you
would receive the income associated with
that amount of ownership
now bankers don't very much like being
cut out of the cash flow loop so they
took another look at mr nakamoto's
curious little white paper
and they've recently been spending a
billion dollars a year in blockchain
research
isn't it ironic satoshi's entire bank
invention is now being used by the banks
to move money faster and by big business
to track supply chains
[Music]
cryptocurrencies and digital tokens
public blockchains private blockchains
where is the killer app
well adoption of new technology often
follows old trends
my name is mark van trusca i'm here at
oxford university oxford on the faculty
i'm an economic sociologist by training
interested in how large scale
infrastructure changes so great to see
you after nine years i know
mark teaches a class on innovation and
system building
he tells me what must align for a new
technology to become fruitful
all technologies start out as
interesting ideas some of them begin to
develop into innovations and we know
that that arc from invention to
innovation takes a lot of time it takes
a lot of work some of those innovations
eventually become commercially viable
case in point the automobile in the
early days cars looked like a pretty
lousy idea and poorly executed
early on there were electric cars there
were battery operated cars the
combustion engine was a relative late
comer
it took henry ford's mass production to
create the standards what a car looked
like what parts it needed how it
operated
that's when complementary assets and
infrastructure emerged
so you have
paved roads and petrol stations then you
have secondary things like motels and
restaurants and places to eat while
you're on the highway and buy food then
you have interesting questions like what
side of the road should we drive on
an entire ecosystem had been built but
it wasn't a smooth transition by any
means
[Music]
the imagery here is there are maybe a
couple of hundred three or four hundred
companies that try to get into this
space but they're not car companies
they're bicycle manufacturers or steam
engine manufacturers at some point in
this in this account all that period of
ferment settles around the dominant
design and then you have what again what
innovation economists would call a
shakeout they would say you go from
three or four hundred producers all of
them vying to
shape this emerging space this emerging
thing called the automobile you may then
drop to 20 or 30 manufacturers and then
you may drop to five or six
it took 50 years for cars to go from
curious invention to finely tune mass
market product
50 years to change the world as we knew
it
your destination is on the left
but our story isn't about cars or roads
i want to learn about dominant designs
of digital technology
that's why i came to the computer
history museum in the heart of silicon
valley so you're looking at the console
for sage which was probably the first
computer network
there were 23 centers around north
america to warn against soviet bombers
and they were waiting for world war iii
the u.s military and some american
universities asked this guy to create a
new kind of network to connect their
separate networks
this young girl
got up and she had a bunch of questions
but her first one was
how did i manage to convince all the
governments of the world to let us build
the internet and i said well except for
the handful of us that were actually
working on the internet
nobody else really thought it was a very
good idea and they didn't think it was
going to lead anywhere and you know we
pretty much had a free running room yes
that's the man who co-invented tcpip
about 50 years ago that's the original
academic paper
you can think of tcp as the backbone of
the internet but back then there were
many competing technologies
there was a very big battle over the
protocols tcp didn't just win by default
um it won through attrition by basically
being better simpler easier to deploy
than all of the other scandals
and more scalable and it had a lot of
competition from
phone companies that tried to make
the internet a closed metered controlled
system they tried to do what people are
trying to do today with blockchains
which is take the open decentralized
network and turn it into this sterile
closed corporate system where they can
charge by the minute and be in control
the internet's ultimate victory has a
dirty little secret the men in charge of
promoting it were employees of the
military with the muscle and the cash to
beat the competition and then there's
email email i heard that's really neat
email was perhaps the internet's first
killer app then in the early 90s tim
berners-lee introduced the world wide
web as a 20-page proposal
soon there were browsers that made it
more accessible and user-friendly for
the general public
i think that the internet is going to be
one of the major forces
for reducing the role of government
the one thing that's missing but that
will soon be developed
is a reliable e-cash still few
understood the potential of this new
tech from people that thought it would
just be
the world's greatest library to
some of the early cypherpunks who are
the
direct fathers of crypto and
certainly uh blockchain type ideas who
thought much as today that it would
create kind of a commons that was
outside of the direct control of normal
laws and governments
that's ironic because the us government
funded it in the first place
the spiritual forefathers of crypto who
built the early internet thought it was
a new technology for global freedom of
expression and a blank canvas upon which
they could build their dreams boy that
sounds familiar
and the media they didn't quite know
what to make of this new thing either
but sure enough they found juicy stories
about the dark side of it
which was the internet is full of
criminals and pedophiles and
pornographers and it's too dangerous to
use your credit card on it it's full of
scams we're seeing the exact same story
now we envisioned technology as if it
were autonomous as if it were simply
outside of human and social experience
what we see are technologies that become
shaped by commercial interests by
political and regulatory infrastructure
by actors who are acting for many
reasons right yeah where do you want me
remember bob
the big telecoms wanted his thoughts on
a little idea they were kicking around
they had a meeting where they were
trying to figure out how they could buy
the internet if they couldn't kill it
well why not own it i got asked that
myself by an executive at a large
information company it was probably in
1990 if they could buy the
i mean internet
remember asking them well why don't you
buy the world economy they can own
everything why don't you buy the weather
and you can control that too
as the internet's momentum and hype grew
investors threw money at entrepreneurs
and shady characters
[Music]
the joke in the dot com era was that you
put a dot-com behind your company even
if it had nothing to do with the
internet and the venture capitalists
just throw money at you
it took a few decades in hype cycles but
the wild internet was eventually
domesticated co-opted by trillion dollar
companies and then fundamentally
transformed how we shop work and
communicate
speaker's corner in london's hyde park
for 150 years this has been a safe place
to stand on a soapbox to sell your ideas
preach the gospel badmouth the king or
promote communism
today with the world wide web we can
stand on giant digital soapboxes using
facebook twitter youtube we can share
our ideas or start a fight with anyone
on the planet
well
almost anyone
of 65 countries studied china has the
least free internet worse than iran cuba
or syria
a police force of more than 2 million
cyber corps and the world's most
sophisticated artificial intelligence
system keep china's web content clean
and users in check
so sorry to break it to you but there's
no longer worldwide web welcome to the
splinternet no it's not just in china
in russia wikipedia is illegal
facebook is outlawed in bangladesh
is no whatsapp in dubai
twitter was banned in turkey after news
about government corruption spread and
saudi arabia shut down the region's
largest news service al jazeera and the
bbc
meanwhile in india the entire web was
turned off 100 times last year
to be fair some of the censorship is to
prevent terrorist recruitment or to stop
violent mobs from hurting people but i
think government's control over the
internet has gone just a little too far
hello i'm from the australian government
do you have something to hide we've
taken the uk's fascist spying law and
made it even more fascist to test this
[ __ ] [ __ ] we chose australia the
weakest of the five eyes alliance thanks
to a lack of a bill of rights so
international data requests will now be
funneled through us compromising not
just aussies but all of you [ __ ] too
you're welcome
hold on satoshi turned money into code
code is just letters and numbers which
is
speech right so money now is speech
which is a pretty powerful idea if you
think about it but if bitcoin is this
uncontrollable unsensible technology
can the blockchain also enable global
free speech
in some places it already does
one chinese student tried to report a
sexual assault and was silenced by her
college but she knew that she could
attach a message into the metadata of an
ethereum transaction
so she spent 15 cents and now her letter
outlining her story and the threat she
received is on the public ethereum
blockchain where it will remain
unchangeable forever
the early crypto pioneers wanted to
democratize money finance 2.0 if you
will but now the believers in the
blockchains have their eyes on a bigger
price
they want to decentralize everything web
3.0
facebook without the propaganda twitter
without the terms of service reddit
without the censorship online identity
without the hex
internet browsing without tracking
software
websites without the advertising
we pay with either attention or privacy
so we either have advertising thrown at
us our attention is monetized or we pay
with micro violations of our privacy and
that is why the internet today is the
ultimate surveillance economy one
privacy tool is the brave browser
it doesn't store data and pays users and
content publishers in their basic
attention tokens
what most people
in the crypto space are
probably most excited about is
this notion that we can create these
kind of user-owned decentralized
networks you can for instance offer file
storage in the way that an amazon does
or that you could offer search you know
the way google does but do it in a
peer-to-peer fashion without this
behemoth at the center extracting rents
and do it in a way where all the people
that are users of it can benefit
lock stack is the next evolution in
computing we've seen three main eras of
computing before we had mainframes that
were these large computers that everyone
depended on then we got desktops where
users were in control and they own their
own computers and their data and
information and then we saw cloud
computing where we are dependent on
these large companies running services
for us and we are about to embark on
this major shift in computing called
decentralized computing where users are
getting back in control
and they really could someday
compete with if not even take down some
of the big
tech giants like the facebooks and the
googles and the amazons that we know
that's a tall tall order it is it is but
i mean who would have thought at the
beginning of the internet that wikipedia
would beat out in cardiac these web 3
promises sound good but my professional
network is on linkedin my personal
photos are on instagram if i deleted my
accounts i'd lose everything these
services aren't just walled gardens they
are digital prisons data is locked up in
several companies
and we don't own it the companies own it
but they use the data to mine it to
advertise to us to sell us things to
manipulate us to
change our behavior and ocean protocols
the answer to freeing up the data and
giving the power back to individuals
so how do we plan to do that
it's essentially an operating system on
top of ethereum
that allows for
people to share data
storage algorithms
and computation in a way that preserves
privacy it's too early to tell whether
projects like these can succeed but i do
like the idea of digital property rights
wouldn't it be nice if companies paid us
in cryptocurrency when they use our data
and if we control who has access to it
instead of our digital overlords
and then there's the question of our
most precious information
our very identity if you take the
history of mankind a lot of blood has
been shared getting to democracy right
the idea that every man has a vote uh in
the world and
you know i take it kind of personally
because i was born in south africa
during apartheid um you know the child
of indian immigrants and we were not
allowed to vote vinnie tells me that in
the united states alone there are 14 000
different paper forms of birth
certificates issued by local authorities
there are mistakes on them and even
identity theft starting from birth
all your information is already out
there there's you know five hacks a day
happening so how do you prove that you
are who you say you are
[Music]
our crypto celebrity andreas has 10
imposters on instagram ryan gosling's
alter ego is committing financial fraud
in bulgaria and who knows what's
happening with your compromised
information
blockchain-based services like civics
identity.com or microsoft's ion say they
can give us control of our identity and
protect it currently we are having our
reputation our history
with different systems of different
companies like facebook and twitter with
the blockchain the core important
information sits on that trusted system
which we control and we can take from
wherever we want to go to something else
meanwhile vitalik has inspired thousands
of software developers to build his
vision of decentralized finance but
early in ethereum's history something
went wrong with one of the first smart
contracts called the dao
the dao went like this they wanted a
completely the decentralized autonomous
organization they wanted a science
fiction dream of an independent computer
program that was immune to human
influence
so what they actually did was build a
forthcoming disaster
the problem
some sloppy code left their safety
deposit box wide open and somebody just
helped themselves
allowed them to pilfer 50 million
dollars from
the smart contract
and
that's why when when i say it's not even
clear whether or not it was a hack you
know the smart contract allowed them to
do that and what happened was the
majority of the community did decide to
roll back
the blockchain
and to pretend like the dow never
happened
yep you heard that correctly the top
decision makers forked ethereum into two
separate networks one where the money
was gone and a new one where the money
was restored to its original owners
breaking the first rule of
cryptocurrency never alter the
blockchain
immutability lasts only as long as the
big boys haven't lost money
just like bitcoin ethereum also
experience scaling problems
when a decentralized app called
cryptokitties
i'm not kidding went viral and the kitty
spread like rabbits in its blockchain
the system ground to a halt
the network is now being upgraded but
there are many competitors who claim
that their blockchains are faster fairer
and more scalable the next shakeout will
surely be interesting to watch
it's never easy to admit that some that
you've been fooled
um
maybe i've been fooled
uh
maybe
the crypto community doesn't agree on
much of anything except when it comes to
this guy
hello my name is dr craig wright i'm the
chief scientist of end chain limited
on the balance of the evidence
craig wright almost certainly is not
satoshi nakamoto the proofs that he gave
were not real proofs in the end he
either chickened out or didn't actually
have the proof craig wright
obviously seems to be a scammer
i'm happy to say that craig wright is a
fraud i know he's controversial no one
really changes the world without being
bold without disrupting people's ideas
and without drawing a little controversy
around the way
but the majority of the industry says
craig is crazy or a con man
so craig
kindly joins the stage and that giving
him screen time is irresponsible
and i'll say this quite frankly because
i've got more money than your country
but i was in the area and just couldn't
resist
[Music]
a few quick facts craig is the person
who claimed to be satoshi nakamoto on
the bbc
but his cryptographic proof didn't check
out
and since then many just see him as an
imposter i'm the guy with a law degree
that used to
work for federal police and military
intelligence
you would actually be the perfect
supervillain for us because everybody
kind of uh doesn't believe you hates you
um what do you say to your critics
uh do i start with a muhahaha
many people
are hated early on because they're not
understood if it doesn't have a use it
shouldn't have a value
right now practically everything is a
ponzi i don't particularly like ethereum
it's a dead end
they can say whatever they want about
erc20 except
practically everything they're doing um
that they want to solve i solved years
ago
decentralization was never the point of
bitcoin
ever i was called a fool then and i'll
be called a fool again
and every single time i'll be right
i picked up um mastering bitcoin the
other day
and i opened page one
and i went this is wrong
silk road was the worst thing to ever
happen to bitcoin you seem to think that
nobody else has anything interesting to
say you've already solved the problems
many years ago that's kind of the the
vibe that i'm getting here fairly much
yes
okay
turns out craig's playbook is patents
some say he's a patent troll
well i've got a bucket list bit which is
to beat edison which
as silly as it sounds came from a
simpsons episode
to beat mr edison i need to get
1085 and
right at the moment i'm on white paper
1074.
for each white paper he claims to file
about 1.1 patents the first 163 will be
very shortly
public next year people are going to
start seeing that we have hundreds of
patents and
everything changes we file pct and keep
them secret as long as we can
that's a huge philosophical disagreement
between myself and uh and craig so i
think government
patents are a government granted
monopoly
the big brains and big egos who broke
away from bitcoin couldn't hash out
their differences so there was another
split
craig's new coin also claims to be the
real bitcoin and he wants to enable
blogs a million times larger updating
and storing this giant blockchain will
be impossible for normal computers i
just can't figure this guy out is he a
genius a madman a fraud maybe all three
and a lot of things he say are very um
or just wrong technically
however i did calculate that n chain
spent tens of millions of dollars to
develop and file these patents
and some have been granted
what's the point of having a war chest
full of ip if they aren't going to
enforce it so basically what i'm looking
at is stuff that nobody's ever really
seen in the community that's correct yes
as soon as the price of bitcoin and the
cryptocurrencies went higher what did
what did most people do
all they did was start adopting all the
worst behaviors of bankers scamming the
market
centralizing wealth in a few hands
i think that's called human nature
so everyone wants to change the world
simply because they're not in the
position of of power as soon as they get
into that position they do exactly the
same thing
so guys like you will build a better
future and we can trust you guys better
than the bankers you don't have to trust
us that's the beauty we're building a
trustless decentralized system that
gives power to people
treason it sounds like there's no trust
but actually it means we don't need to
trust you i think the better word should
be trust free
about one third or maybe half of all the
cost of all the transactions are paid to
establish trust between trading parties
like we're paying for
lawyers we're paying
auditors who are paying even police even
regulators government to to build trust
to ensure everything will be enforced so
trust is quite expensive blockchain is
the first time that we saw some
technology that can
eliminate the cost or reduce the cost of
trust dramatically magical things will
happen
trust may be expensive but it's also in
short supply
all around the globe people have been
losing faith in the media institutions
and governments so what if this new
technology could fix one of society's
biggest issues but the question remains
what if you are cheated what if your
password is stolen and the money the
contracts your identity is gone
if code is law
who administers justice
aren't you worried that the promise of
decentralizing power is kind of in
jeopardy with you and charlie and
vitalik and craig
as such central figureheads
yeah i really wish there weren't
public figures or leaders i want
everyone to lead themselves but sadly
that's not the world we live in if
you're going to look to a leader you
know choose your leader wisely
but just how different are they from our
current political financial and business
leaders are their systems really
resistant to corruption immune to
manipulation and worthy of our trust
maybe that's why the best bet is on the
only project without a figurehead
bitcoin doesn't care about human drama
bad press or what anyone thinks
yeah sure it hasn't succeeded as a
global currency yet but in the past
decade it has been the world's best
performing financial asset
so we're back to where we started
the genius who vanished
with satoshi being gone from bitcoin
bitcoin is really a very decentralized
networking currency he was intelligent
enough to know that
a system without a father was going to
be much more robust than a system with a
father
no father maybe but without leaving a
will the kids are now fighting over the
meaning of his invention and the
inheritance
projecting their fears and their
fantasies onto his legacy
for some it's money for the internet
that can replace middlemen and bank the
unbanked and maybe a tool for illicit
trade or is it digital gold a totally
new asset class
a bet against the bankers an insurance
against inflation protection from
corrupt politicians
and a weapon against the state
maybe the end of money as we know it
for some entrepreneurs it represents a
shortcut to fund their dreams
a platform for fairer finance which is
why incumbents fight it
some say public blockchains are just
slow and useless databases while big
business is busy building private
blockchains to boost efficiency or maybe
this decentralized technology is a new
protocol layer for the internet upon
which we can build a better web
to dethrone the tech giants reclaim free
speech protect online identities and
facilitate free trade in a borderless
digital economy oh and a tool to rebuild
trust in our societies and yes maybe
even save the planet
that's a never-ending list of kryptopian
ideas
isn't this a bit too much to ask of a
nine page document
yeah sure the internet and the web
started out as white papers too
but it took decades before its
infrastructure was built became user
friendly and ready to scale globally we
kind of domesticate the wild potential
of technologies into what's familiar and
we dramatically underestimate or under
imagine what that technology may
eventually do
it'll be the users maybe billions of
them who will adopt this technology
without even knowing what a blockchain
is or how it works
because here's the thing the average
users don't care about the wires that
move their money quicker don't know
about the software that moves this movie
or that picture
what will move them are services that
will make the days a little brighter
their chores a little lighter
and their lives a little
richer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
that guy's fix code run simple known
this is new money production top brand
woods over listed good this is a weapon
of mass destruction
that late
confident in her twitch says she takes
on the haters but nothing can break the
world could be much safer and our
freedom quite greater and it's all in
this white paper
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is gone